we just got some bombshell leaks for
next year's watch models according to
mixture quo next year's apple watch
lineup is gonna include the series eight
the second gen apple watch se and a new
extreme sports version they actually
think that apple could call this one the
pro model what if all the leaks that we
were seeing about the flat sided apple
watch were actually for the extreme
sports model that apple decided to delay
by another year i personally think that
the new flat sided design makes sense
because it would actually make it a lot
more durable and on top of that apple
could use a new titanium alloy as the
casing material for this watch we should
be expecting some updated internal specs
and new sensors like for measuring body
temperature and more apple would adopt
new solid state buttons that don't
physically click and the main benefit of
this is that it would further improve
water resistance and they would also
take up less internal space leaving more
room for a bigger battery or other
components